how to boost growth in Europe one
doctrine is innovation and support for
small and medium-sized enterprises the
biggest drivers of growth but since the
crisis financing has become much tougher
for them now MEP is meeting in the
Economic Affairs Committee want to
unlock more through a capital markets
union CMU there is a lot of financial
resources across the U and the world and
not enough for financing for SMEs
so we will work here in order to make
CMU also a tool to support SMEs
is a big opportunity but a lot of work
to do the capital markets Union could be
rolled out by 2018 perpetual worries
about the Greek financial crisis with no
resolution in sight a debt repayment of
1.6 billion euros to the International
Monetary Fund is due at the end of June
the financial markets too are demanding
a stability that's hard to find I can
assure you the DCB is doing all it can
to facilitate successful if we lose a
member state or if at least there is a
default I fear that all the efforts we
have made to strengthen investments and
to support growth will vanish
while all actors will now need to go the
extra mile the bold lies squarely in the
camp of the Greek government as the last
lap of talks begins between the EU
institutions on data protection rules
young Philipp Albers the MEP leading
negotiations for Parliament explains why
he thinks the new role will help eat you
companies doing business online
companies in Europe have to realize that
this law if we pass it will be one of
the biggest subsidies to European IT
business which we ever did because we
minimize bureaucracy to an absolute
minimum we create a level playing field
and we ask all the players coming from
the outside to the market so our
competitors to respect the same rules as
we do
clock waves as the French far-right
politician marine lepen finally
succeeded in forming Parliament's eighth
political group after a British
right-wing populists gave the fondazione
a leader enough support Parliament's
Committee on women's rights and gender
equality this week voted in favor of
recommendations to encourage more girls
to take up science they're much less
likely to study technical subjects
automatic science and engineering in
need to have a good balance in basically
every and each sector of our life and
also of course in school in preschool in
kindergarten in University